S
A LOOK AT THE SITUATION ON THE
GROUND.
>> Reporter: IN A RECENTLY
OVERRUN ARMY PAYS IN NORTHERN
AFGHANISTAN, TALIBAN SHOW
WEAPONS AND AMMUNITION.
CNN CANNOT VERIFY THE
AUTHENTICITY OR THE DATE THEY
WERE FILLED.
AFGHAN SECURITY OFFICIALS COULD
NOT CONFIRM OR DENY TALIBAN
CLAIMS IN THESE VIDEOS TO CNN.
THEY DO ADMIT TO LOSING DOZENS
OF TOWNS IN THE PAST FORTNIGHT.
THE TALIBAN CLAIM 90 SUCH
VICTORIES IN THE PAST MONTH.
THE U.S. SAYS IT'S LESS, 50 OF
370 GONE, BUT STILL VERY
CONCERNING.
>> MOST DISTRICTS THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKEN SURROUND PROVINCIAL
CAPITALS, SUGGESTING THAT THE
TALIBAN ARE POSITIONING
THEMSELVES TO TRY AND PARTICULAR
THESE CAPITALS ONCE FOREIGN
FORCES ARE FULLY WITHDRAWN.
>> Reporter: AT TIMES THE
TALIBAN CLAIMING WINS WITHOUT
FIRING A SHOT.
ATTACKING A PROVINCE, A WHOLE
COLUMN OF AMERICAN MADE HUMVEES
SURRENDERED.
THEY DUMP THEIR GUNS IN A PILE,
A VALUABLE BOOST FOR THE
TALIBAN.
AFGHAN GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS SAY
THEY'RE SENDING REINFORCEMENTS
TO TAKE BACK CONTROL AND CLAIM
WITHOUT PROOF TO HAVE KILLED
HUNDREDS OF TALIBAN.
THE TALIBAN OFFENSIVE APPEARS TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE U.S. AND
NATO DRAWDOWN, LIMITING AIR
SUPPORT FOR AFGHAN TROOPS ON THE
GROUND, AND RAISES QUESTIONS
ABOUT THEIR INTENT THAT PEACE
TALKS IN DOHA WITH THE AFGHAN
GOVERNMENT, IT'S ALSO
SIGNIFICANT THAT THEY'RE
ATTACKING THE NORTH.
I COVERED THE AFGHAN CONFLICT IN
THE 90s WHEN THEY WERE FIGHTING
THEIR WAY UP THE COUNTRY.
IT TOOK YEARS TO GET TO THE
NORTH.
THIS WILL SEND A VERY CHILLY
MESSAGE TO AFGHANS.
THE TALIBAN SURGE ALSO A CONCERN
FOR U.S. FORCES WHO AGREED THEIR
OWN CEASE-FIRE WITH THE TALIBAN
AS THEY EXIT THEIR LONGEST WAR
BUT HOPED THEY MIGHT LEAVE THE
COUNTRY AT PEACE
>> EVERY DAY THE SITUATION IN
AFGHANISTAN CHANGES, AS THE
TALIBAN CONTINUED TO CONDUCT
THESE ATTACKS AND TO RAID
DISTRICT CENTERS AS WELL AS THE
VIOLENCE, WHICH IS STILL TOO
HIGH.
>> Reporter: ON FRIDAY,
PRESIDENT MEETS PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HARD TO SEE AN EASY REVERSE.
>>> MY NEXT GUEST WRITES AFGHAN
WOMEN TURNED THEIR BURQAS INTO A
TOOL FOR FEMINIST ACTIVISM
SHOWING THE WORLD WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AND HOPING THE WORLD
WOULD RESPOND.
LENA JOINS ME, THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE LEBANESE
AMERICAN UNIVERSITY.
I SPOKE TO A WOMAN OF DOHA
NEGOTIATING WITH THE TALIBAN AT
PRESENT.
HAVE A LISTEN TO WHAT SHE TOLD
ME.
.
>> I THINK I FEEL BETRAYAL.
BEING AN ALLY FOR 20 YEARS,
BEING IN FRONT, PROMOING THE
VALUES OF HUMAN RIGHTS,
DEMOCRACY, EDUCATION OF THE
THINGS THAT PEOPLE FROM
AFGHANISTAN VERY WELL DESERVED,
BEING, YOU KNOW, THE PORTRAIT OF
AN ACHIEVEMENT FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL ACHIEVEMENT IN
AFGHANISTAN, NOW THEY DO NOT
EVEN CONSULT WOMEN OF
AFGHANISTAN.
>> SHE FEELS, LENA, BETRAYED.
YOUR RESPONSE.
>> THANK YOU.
I THINK HER SENTIMENTS ARE
ECHOED ACROSS AFGHANISTAN.
AFTER TWO DECADES AND AMERICA'S
LONGEST WAR AND SO MUCH RHETORIC
TO LIBERATE AFGHAN WOMEN, IT IS
WORTH ASKING IF THAT HAS BEEN
ACHIEVED.
AND I THINK THEY WOULD ARGUE IT
HASN'T.
THERE'S BEEN A BACKSLIDING IN
TERMS OF GAINS MADE.
AND AFGHAN WOMEN ARE HOLDING
THEIR BREATH.
THEY ARE RESTING ON VERY
PRECARIOUS GROUND.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY HAVE BEEN
ACTIVELY LIBERATING THEMSELVES
SINCE THE VERY BEGINNING.
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
SINCE BEFORE WE ARRIVED.
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO
AFTER WE LEAVE.
BUT WHAT WE OWE THEM IS A BETTER
RESPONSE, GREATER SUPPORT, AND
TO FULFILL THE COMMITMENTS THAT
WE MADE TO THEM IN THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE INTERVENTION.
>> LOOK, WE ALL KNOW WHAT THE
TALIBAN'S APPROACH TOWARDS WOMEN
AND WOMEN'S EDUCATION IS AS MY
COLLEAGUE WAS JUST REPORTING.
THE GROUP IS GAINING MORE
CONTROL PARTICULARLY IN THE
NORTH OF THE COUNTRY.
JUST HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU
SHOULD THEY TAKE OVER, A LARGE
SWATH OF THE COUNTRY AND GROW
STRONGER, WHAT THE IMPACT MIGHT
BE FOR THE WOMEN OF AFGHANISTAN?
>> ALREADY THE IMPACT IS VERY
SERIOUS.
WE HAVE SEEN GREATER HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS, MORE SCHOOL
CLOSURES, INCREASED AGAINST
WOMAN.
AFGHANISTAN IS THE WORST PLACE
TO BE A WOMAN.
IT IS QUITE SERIOUS.
EVEN THOUGH THERE HAVE BEEN
GAINS MADE WE HAVE TWO-THIRDS OF
GIRLS OUT OF SCHOOL, WITH
WOMEN'S LITERACY FOR INSTANCE
THERE HAVE BEEN IMPROVEMENTS.
70% OF WOMEN AND GIRLS STILL
CAN'T READ OR WRITE.
FOR ME THE MOST ALARMING
SITUATION IS VIOLENCE AGAINST
WOMEN.
THAT IS INCREASING.
80%, IF NOT MONTH OR WOMEN AND
GIRLS HAVE EXPERIENCED ABUSE.
MANY IN THE HOME.
WOMEN'S SECURITY IN THE HOME IS
A REFLECTION OF THE SECURITY IN
THE COUNTRY.
IF WOMEN CAN'T BE SAFE AT HOME,
THEY'RE NOT SAFE AT ALL.
IF WOMEN ARE NOT SAFE, NO ONE IS
SAFE.
THEY SHOULD BE THE BAROMETER IN
WHICH THE ENTIRE SITUATION IS
JUDGED.
WHEN I LIVED THERE, I SPENT FOUR
YEARS WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
AFGHAN WOMEN.
WHAT I SAW WAS STRENGTH,
RESILIENCE AND COURAGE AND THE
ABILITY TO SPEAK OUT AND STRONG
VOICES.
BUT ARE WE LISTENING?
DO THEY HAVE A MICROPHONE?
ARE WE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO AMPLIFY THE WORK THEY ARE
ALREADY DOING?
>> AND OF COURSE INVOLVED IN
THESE PEACE TALKS, THESE TALKS
WITH THE TALIBAN, AND SHE
CONTINUES OF COURSE TO PLAY A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE AND WILL DO IN
ANYTHING, ANY FUTURE FOR THOSE
TALKS WRFR THEY MIGHT BE.
BUT ULTIMATELY, HOW CONCERNED
ARE YOU THAT THE TALKS ARE
STALLED.
IT SEEMS THE TALIBAN ISN'T GOING
ANYWHERE.
>> WELL, I HAVE WORKED IN
CONFLICT CONTEXT WORLDWIDE.
I HAVE SEEN IN WOMEN ARE NOT
ENGAGED IN EVERY ASPECT OF THE
PEACE PROCESS, IT IS A PIECE ON
SHAKY GROUND.
WHEN WOMEN ARE INVOLVED, THAT
PIECE IS BETTER, STRONGER AND
LASTS LONGER.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT ABSOLUTELY
EVERYWHERE.
IF AFGHAN WOMEN ARE SAYING THEY
ARE NOT INVOLVED OR COMFORTABLE
WITH THE WAY THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED, THAT IS A VERY SHAKY
PIECE.
SO I IN FACT, AM VERY WORRIED
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID THE
AMERICAN WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN IS JUSTIFIABLE
BECAUSE HE SAID FORCES HAVE MADE
CERTAIN THAT AFGHANISTAN CANNOT
AGAIN BECOME A BASE FOR FOREIGN
JIHADIST TO PLOT AGAINST THE
WEST.
THAT WITHDRAW, HE SAYS, WILL BE
COMPLETE BY SEPTEMBER 11th,
2021, A SYMBOLIC DAY, THE
20-YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THE
FALLING OF THE TWIN TOWERS
BLAMED ON AL QAEDA, HARBORED BY
THE TALIBAN IN AFGHANISTAN.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT
ASSESSMENT?
YOU KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON IN AFGHANISTAN.
DO YOU AGREE THAT THIS WITHDRAW
IS RIGHT, JUSTIFIABLE,
RESPONSIBLE AT THIS POINT?
>> I THINK THERE'S A RISK OF A
LEADERSHIP VACUUM, AND IT COULD
JEOPARDIZE THE GAINS OF WOMEN.
THE OCCUPATION EVENTUALLY HAS TO
END.
BUT WHAT I WOULD HOPE TO SEE IS
A RESPONSIBLE END, AN
ACCOUNTABLE END AND ONE THAT IS
ACCOUNTABLE IN PARTICULAR TO
AFGHAN WOMEN.
AND IF WOMEN, LIKE I SAID, ARE
NOT ENGAGED, THERE IS NO
POSSIBILITY OF PEACE IN THE
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT HAVE BEEN
ACTIVELY WORKING FOR IT.
THEY HAVE BEEN FIGHTING BATTLES,
RUNNING SCHOOLS, RISKING THEIR
OWN LIVES TO EDUCATE THEIR
GIRLS.
THEY HAVE SHOWN US THE ABUSES OF
THE TALIBAN.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO NEED TO BE
LEADING THIS PEACE.
>> YEAH.
YESTERDAY WHEN I WAS SPEAKING TO
HER SAID SHE IS SO DISAPPOINTED.
SHE WAS EFFECTIVELY, SHE FELT
THAT THE AMERICANS WITHDRAWING
WOULD CERTAINLY AT LEAST USE
THEIR LEVERAGE TO ENSURE THAT
THERE WAS SOME SORT OF PEACE
PROCESS STILL MANY ONGOING AS IT
WERE AND THE AMERICANS PUSHED TO
ENSURE PROSPECTS FOR PIECE AND
STABILITY PARTICULARLY FOR WOMEN
GOING FORWARD.
DO YOU SHARE HER DISAPPOINTMENT,
HER SENSE OF BETRAYAL?
>> I ABSOLUTELY SHARE HER
CONCERNS.
AND WHAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT IS
THAT WE SHOULD BE FUNDING THE
VERY ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
WORKING ON THE GROUND, THE
AFGHAN WOMEN'S GROUPS, THE
FEMINISTS, FRONTLINE WORKERS
LEADING THE CHARGE FOR CHANGE
SINCE THE BEGINNING.
AND IF THEY ARE THE ONES SAYING
THEY ARE NOT INVOLVED, THEY ARE
AFRAID, THEY DON'T HAVE THE
TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO
ADVANTAGE, THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT LOSING FUNDAMENTAL
FREEDOMS AND RIGHTS, THAT IS A
CONCERN AND RAISES AN ALARM FOR